مع حلول سيف العام 2010 شكل ارتفاع
الحراره غير المسبوق في روسيا لمده شهرين
اذانا بفتره جفاف طويله لكن احدا لم يتوقع
انها تنذر بكارثه كبرى سيقع ضحيتها اكثر
من 55,000 شخص ومئات المصابين فما القصه
في منتصف يونيو كانت موسكو على موعد مع
اسوء موجه حراره عرفتها البلاد منذ اكثر
من 130 عاما حيث ارتفعت درجه الحراره الى
40 درجه مئويه في الظل اي بزياده 25 درجه
عن معدلها السنوي ما اسفر عن اشتعال
الحرائق في الاجزاء الغربيه والوسطى من
البلاد او ما يعرف بالاجزاء الاوروبيه من
الاتحاد الروسي
طب ما الابلاغ عن اكثر من 800 حريق هائل
بعشرين من منطقه واشتاحت الحرائق عده الاف
من الهكترات واعلنت حاله الطوارئ في سبع
مناطق حيث يعيش 17 مليون شخص في ما حضرت
الدوله تصدير القمح والمواد المشتقه منه
التهمت النيران المستعره المنازل والاشجار
وحقول المزارعين واحرقت اكثر من 150 تجمعا
ريفيه
منزل في الاجزاء الاوروبيه وجبال الاورال
وغربي سيبيريا
انتشرت الحرائق الى شرق موسكو وجففت
المستنقعات والممرات المائيه
كما شكلت تحديدا كبيرا عندما امتدت باتجاه
مركزا للصواريخ النوويه خارج موسكو وسط
مخاوف من ارتفاع النيدات المشعه ونشوء
منطقه تلوث نوويه ليتم نقل المواد المشعه
والمعدات العسكريه الى مناطق بعيده
تسبب الدخان الكثيف في تعطيل الرحلات
الجويه الى موسكو وعان عشره ملايين اخرون
في موسكو من الدخان وحجبت الرؤيه على
مدارج مطار توم وجيري
كما ساعدت عده دول في عمليات الانقاذ من
خلال تقديم المساعدات من طائرات ورجال
اطفاء وما ساعد على اطفاء معظم الحرائق مع
حلول منتصف اغسطس فيما ساعد بدء هطول
الامطار على تحسن الوضع في معظم مناطق وسط
روسيا الا ان الامور بقيت صعبه في جبال
الاورال وجنوب سيبيريا حتى سبتمبر كما
تسببت الحرائق في تشريد اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف شخص
اثرت الكارثه على اكثر من
13,300,000 هكتار في احدى واربعين مقاطعه
روسيه كما تم تقديره نسب الخسائر الزراعيه
بثلث محصول الحبوب الروسي لعام 2010
اما حجم الخسائر الاقتصاديه فتم تقديره من
15 مليار دولار الى 300 مليار دولار
بعد الحادثه تخصصت الحكومه اموالا لبناء
مبان لضحايا الحرائق كما واجه المسؤولون
المحليون في روسيا اتهامات وعقوبات باتخاد
اجراءات غير كافيه لمنع الحرائق والفشل في
الاستجابه لكن المزارعين كانوا الخاسر
الاكبر بعد ان ذهب شقاء عامهم ادراج
الرياح
[موسيقى]